il nettoie la bichonne l'a fait briller
il en prend soin comme un bébé
ce n'est qu'une voiture mais frédéric
jung y est très attaché à ce corps c'est
une belle bagnole c'est la première
tesla décapotable vendus à l'extérieur
des états unis
je lis depuis 2008 elle marche bien très
agréable à conduire
c'est une auto électrique
ce militant écologiste ne conduit plus
que ça depuis près de 30 ans je ne vois
pas le besoin de polluer pour me
déplacer
mon but est de me rendre à destination
pas de cohue en fait
fredrik org aime tellement les voitures
électriques les tesla en particulier
qu'il en a même deux une sportive pour
s'amuser et une berline pour aller
travailler
s'il apparaissait comme un animal
étrange en 1989 en important la première
auto électrique au pays
l'écologiste n'est plus du tout
marginale regardez il y encore une autre
tesla la base qu'une voiture sur cinq
aujourd'hui vendue en norvège est
entièrement électrique
c'est de loin le pays le plus avancé
dans le domaine conséquence d'une
politique gouvernementale
résolument en faveur des véhicules
électriques une série de mesures
franchement avantageuse mais pas pour
les péages sur l'autoroute
ni les traversiers le parking est
gratuit partout et puis on peut conduire
sur les voies réservées pour les astuces
ce qui permet de gagner
des milliers de points de chargement
gratuits ont aussi été installés partout
à travers le pays et surtout les
acheteurs d'autos électriques ne paient
ni taxes de vente ni frais
d'enregistrement
il est très important d'inciter les gens
essaient des nouvelles technologies et
pour les rendre attrayantes
il faut une taxation favorable la
norvège qui doit sa richesse au pétrole
s'est fixé des objectifs de réduction de
gaz à effet de serre très ambitieux
moins 40% d'ici 2030 par rapport aux
niveaux de 1990 et l'automobile est vu
comme un secteur névralgique
nous avons vraiment comme objectif de
devenir une société à faible émission de
carbone est actuellement les transports
génèrent un tiers des gaz à effet de
serre transportation les mesures on
fonctionnait bien au delà des espérances
pionnier dans le domaine de la voiture
électrique
le fabricant américain tesla a été
submergée de demandes
la norvège pays d'à peine cinq millions
d'habitants est aujourd'hui l'un de ses
plus gros marchés
c'est en norvège nous a pris par
surprise
on s'attendait à ce que les mesures
fiscales favorisant n'imaginais pas que
ce serait aussi important
la tesla model s qui offre une autonomie
de plusieurs centaines de kilomètres
compte parmi les voitures les plus
vendues au pays populaire ici il ya même
des tests à taxi
du coup les autres constructeurs
automobiles ont dû s'adapter et offrir
aussi des modèles électriques
la golf par exemple est aujourd'hui la
voiture la plus vendue chez volkswagen
toutes catégories chez nissan si la leaf
plus grosses vendeuses c'est la leaf et
de loin elle représente 2 puis 4 1 50%
de nos bars forêt s en quatre ans le
marché des autos entièrement électrique
a littéralement explosé en norvège il y
en aura à la fin de l'année puis de 70
milles soit près de 30 fois plus qu'au
québec
dix mille tesla vendus par exemple
contre à peine plus de 16 ans chez nous
on espère que d'autres pays vont faire
la même chose que ce qu'on a fait ici ça
inciterait les constructeurs à offrir
plus de voitures électriques
et ça permettrait de faire baisser les
prix et chypre bien sûr le modèle
norvégien ne peut pas facilement être
transposée à l'étranger du moins pas est
également car ce qui rend les autos
électriques si concurrentiel
ici c'est que les taxes sur les voitures
à essence et diesel sont très élevés
jusqu'à doubler le prix d'achat d'un
véhicule et que le gouvernement
norvégien peut facilement compter sur
l'argent du pétrole pour financer ces
mesures très coûteuse tous cependant
s'entendent sur une chose c'est que de
bonnes leçons peuvent être tirées de ce
qui se fait ici
atteint boîte de voir je pense que la
norvège a prouvé c'est que les mesures
incitatives fonctionne c'est un bon
moyen de pousser le marché dans la
direction souhaitée
c'est un choix politique le québec est
souvent comparé à la norvège même
population
même climat même abondance
d'hydroélectricité bon marché frédéric
ardent est convaincu le modèle norvégien
marche et tous devraient maintenant sont
expirés utah ksour 30
il faut taxer ce qui pollue gens il
récompenser ceux qui ne produit pas les
taxes ont vraiment efficace pour changer
le comportement des consommateurs les
pays riches se sont développées en
émettant beaucoup de co2 c'est comme un
emprunt à la banque et maintenant ils
ont un devoir de le renverser en classe
quand il repense à ce combat qu'il mène
depuis près de 30 ans l'écologiste n'est
pas peu fier du chemin parcouru
we are back on a démontré qu'un petit
pays de cinq millions d'habitants peut
vraiment influencé n'est dustrit
automobile et ça j'en suis très fier et
s'il s'inquiète que jamais des
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
il se dit aujourd'hui optimiste la
technologie selon lui hélas ne manque
plus que la volonté de l'implanter à
wimereux
les éoliennes les panneaux solaires les
autos électriques et maintenant même
état tout électrique auront pu y arriver
si on veut ramener des points